and this is we're thinking about too and
this is part of the Pareto distribution
problem is that success is
disproportionately rewarded it's not
linear so as you start to succeed the
problem each success nonlinearly
increases the probability of the next
success right so the doors open yeah
yeah yeah that's right
and not one door but they open
exponentially right exactly and so and
as you fail they close exponentially so
you might think well sale yer success
linear it's like no failure success
right so once you start to fail good
luck to you right because each failure
increases the probability of the next
failure in a nonlinear Mouse fashion and
that really if you're on a downhill
trend man that's really vicious and it's
hard to get out of it you see that
happened to big companies when they
start to go into a death spiral they
can't pull themselves out of it but by
the same token when you start to succeed
each success increases the probability
of the next one you actually even see
that with lobsters so back to the
crustaceans well and it's so interesting
that some of these things are so
fundamental that they appear so low in
the phylogenetic chain so if you if you
tally up you watch a lobster engage in
sequence sequential dominance disputes
so basically physical challenges
his probability if he loses the problem
if he loses a battle the probability
that he'll lose the next battle is
higher than you would expect if you just
derived a linear function that was a
consequence of the tally of his previous
victories and losses so because he's
lost he's more likely to lose harder the
next time but if he wins he's
statistically more likely to win so and
and that also drives well that's a
fundamental issue too that drives the
disproportionate distribution of
productive goods and material resources
which is a very big problem it's another
thing you have an intelligent discussion
about and